[Applauso]
[Musica]
Siamo in un ristorante di lusso Il
titolare è un grande chef uno dei
migliori al mondo in questo ambiente
tutto è all'insegna della qualità cura
il dettaglio ricerca della perfezione
una sera di riordinata una crostatina al
limone per dessert e per errore
distrazione cade si spappola oltre a
frantumarsi piatto
arriva lo chef
Secondo voi come reagisce
Ma insomma non possiamo commettere
errori del genere nel nostro ristorante
oppure non ti preoccupare un errore di
poco conto in fin dei conti ti aiuta a
sistemare
allo chef Guarda pensa e poi abbiamo
l'idea per un nuovo dessert
da quel giorno in quel ristorante la
crostatina al limone viene preparata in
modo diverso viene capovolta rotta ad
arte e poi servita è diventato un piatto
iconico con un nome un po' particolare
Ops Mi è caduta la crostatina al limone
[Applauso]
cosa ha fatto qui lo chef come leader
del suo ristorante ha lavorato di
leggerezza lui ha alleggerito il peso e
l'errore lo ha in qualche modo
valorizzato e ci ha ricavato una nuova
idea
e quindi sostanzialmente Noi siamo
leader Quando
cerchiamo di tirar fuori il meglio delle
altre persone e quindi non soltanto
quando abbiamo delle reazioni per cui
diciamo Le scarichiamo Le scarichiamo
sugli altri lui siamo abituati a pensare
ai leader come soggetti della
personalità forte
dominante magari ingombranti persone che
vogliono decidere e cercano di fare
tutto per raggiungere i loro obiettivi
spesso individuali
pensiamo anche alle immagini con cui li
associamo con cui ne parliamo Abbiamo la
macchina da guerra abbiamo lo schiaccia
sassi abbiamo il
Tank il Panzer lo squalo
l'orco il lupo che pesantezza
ci sono esempi diversi Sì ci sono esempi
di leader che noi vogliamo seguire
perché ci ispirano perché noi perché ci
portano a pensare a immaginare qualcosa
di meglio della nostra realtà uno dei
miei esempi preferiti e Malala yousassy
è un attivista pakistana che che
lotta per il diritti all'istruzione nel
mondo pensate a soli 16 anni nel 2013
lei ha condiviso in assemblea delle
Nazioni Unite La sua visione
dell'Istruzione come strumento di pace
un bambino un insegnante una penna e un
libro possono cambiare il mondo e allora
Malala ci insegna che non importa Se hai
16 anni oppure 80 se sei uomo o donna
ragazzino ragazzina da che paese
provieni che lavoro fai
se i leader quando aiuti gli altri a
tirar fuori il meglio di se stessi e
quando li ispiri a tirar fuori il meglio
di se stessi
io per anni ho avuto a che fare con
cinesi indiani brasiliani russi e
un'altra ventina di diverse culture e
nella vera a che fare con persone così
diverse per età religione razza e
cultura Io mi sono sempre chiesto Ma
quand'è che noi diamo il meglio di noi
stessi e non intendo soltanto sul lavoro
Potrebbe essere in uno sport iniziativa
di volontariato fino a qualsiasi cosa
nella quale noi crediamo e che facciamo
Noi diamo il meglio di noi stessi quando
stiamo bene quando diamo significato
quello che facciamo e quando sentiamo di
contribuire di avere un impatto in
qualcosa in cui crediamo
E allora la leggerezza diventa uno
strumento molto potente per creare
ambienti e situazioni in cui le persone
possano stare bene e fare la differenza
c'è una ricerca internazionale che ha
calcolato la differenza di produttività
che noi abbiamo sul lavoro tra quando
siamo infelici e quando stiamo bene
questa differenza è del 250 per cento
E allora la domanda per noi è quante
volte ci capita di dare il nostro 250
per cento
ricordo ad esempio il mio primo
colloquio lavorativo mi aveva chiamato
una nota società di consulenza era il
mio primo colloquio ero appena laureato
Io ci tenevo a fare bella figura
la manager entra nella stanza e con
diversi minuti in ritardo non si scusa
Guarda a me poi guarda il curriculum poi
guarda di nuovo me e poi mi lancia la
prima domanda dritta negli occhi
Ma lei
pensa di poter fare il consulente con
quella faccia lì
[Musica]
Oddio che fa che faccia ciò mi chiedo
Mentre c'è gente non so neanche bene
come rispondere non so se alzarmi
andarmene oppure rispondere per le rime
oppure magari buttarla un po' sul ridere
sdrammatizzando con un Paolo Conte con
quella faccia un po' così
quell'espressione un po' così
La realtà è che io non riesco a
rispondere lei mi ha distrutto da quel
momento in poi ogni volta che lei
rivolge lo sguardo nella mia direzione
io mi immagino che faccia deformata stia
guardando
il colloquio è un calvario non finisce
più Non vedo l'ora che finisca e
finalmente quando mi congeda con le
parole che per una volta buona
le apprezzo con cura che sono le faremo
sapere cioè Ok io torno a casa con un
senso di umiliazioni di sconfitta
Poi però penso no no no no no
crea la mia manager Sono io che rifarò
sapere che non voglio lavorare con gente
come voi perché la sintonia è importante
perché quando c'è sintonia con le
persone con cui abbiamo a che fare noi
stiamo bene e la sintonia non è soltanto
una questione di buon feeling ha a che
fare col funzionamento dei nostri
cervelli
ce lo dicono ai neuroscienze che hanno
indagato cosa accade ai nostri cervelli
in un momento di valutazione come
potrebbe essere questo colloquio
se la manager fosse stata in grado di
creare un clima di leggerezza di
facilità di fiducia tra di noi dopo 15
minuti
le onde cerebrali dei nostri cervelli si
sarebbero Allineate e sarebbero
confluite in un unico cervello chiamato
cervello sociale
capite quanto è forte la comunicazione
che ci può essere quando c'è un unico
cervello invece che due
evidentemente questo non è successo con
la manager anzi voglio specificare che i
nostri cervelli sono stati ben distanti
e ben distinti
Ma c'è un'altra storia che vi voglio
raccontare questa Riguarda il basket
americano è il 15 maggio del 1980 i Los
Angeles Lakers sfilano il Philadelphia
76xrs nelle finali NBA per il titolo al
meglio delle sette partite
la partita precedente Los Angeles ha
vinto la partita e si appresta a volare
su Philadelphia Dove giocherà la partita
decisiva per il titolo i Lakers
dovrebbero essere contenti elettrizzati
pronti a giocare questa partita decisiva
e invece sono preoccupatissimi
perché Karima puggiavari il giocatore
più forte la stella e soprattutto quello
a cui ci si affida nei momenti di
massima difficoltà sia infortunato a
un'anca e non soltanto non potrà giocare
ma non può nemmeno volare con i compagni
a Philadelphia per sostenerli in questa
partita decisiva
sono tutti preoccupati tranne uno
è un ragazzo giovane non ancora 21 anni
è un esordiente praticamente un
ragazzino debuttante il suo nome è
pervin Johnson dal liceo lo
soprannominano Magic
Magic un piano passerà l'intero volo a
parlare coi compagni
Ma ragazzi ma là fuori ci danno tutti
per spacciati e quindi questo per noi è
un grande vantaggio
un compagno lo interrompe si Magi tante
belle storie con la filosofia Però come
facciamo senza Carini
ecco voi di questo non vi dovete
preoccupare ragazzi a sostituire carinci
penso io voi pensate a dare il meglio
che avete
ce la farei il giorno dopo la partita è
chiaramente punto appunto sono due
squadre fortissime e arriviamo a metà a
metà tempo a 60-60 come punteggio
perfetta parità
ma Magicland secondo tempo Sale in
cattedra sarà protagonista di una
partita mostruosa 42 punti 15 rimbalzi 7
assist e così i suoi compagni Jamal
Wheels 37 punti 10 rimbalzi Michael
Cooper 16 punti e persino un panchinaro
come Brad Holland che non che ha giocato
pochissimo di stagione ha giocato
pochissimo nella sua carriera segna 8
punti decisivi
i Lakers spaccano Philadelphia hai una
grandissima Vittoria 123 a 107 e al
fischio finale tutti abbracciano magiche
a metà campo ma lui vuole fare una cosa
passa un giornalista Gli strappa il
microfono e manda un messaggio diretto
in telecamera a Karin che a casa in non
ha potuto partecipare alla partita
fratello ce l'abbiamo fatta e l'abbiamo
fatto per te Adesso lo so che ti fa male
là anche Ma ti prego alzati e palla
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Noi stiamo bene quando qualcuno ci aiuta
a guardare con leggerezza a Sfide anche
audaci
e soprattutto stiamo bene quando nei
momenti di difficoltà
c'è qualcuno che si prende cura di noi
e ci copre le spalle sulle sue spalle
disponibile a prendere più pesi per
lasciare noi liberi di esprimerci
leggeri nel farlo
ma non è bellissimo costruire le cose
così insieme alle persone
quando c'è qualcuno che ti aiuta a tirar
fuori il meglio di te come ha fatto
Magic
quando c'è qualcuno come Malala che ci
ispira con una visione che ci eleva
quando c'è qualcuno che anche se
commettiamo un errore
ci tutela ci protegge ci valorizza come
nel caso dello chef
Sì è bellissimo era leggerezza nella
leadership in realtà è anche molto
efficace perché quando le persone si
esprimono al meglio che possono arrivare
di conseguenza grandi risultati
Ora io vorrei fare una piccola cosa
insieme a voi se siete d'accordo Vorrei
costruire una piccola cosa insieme a voi
Adesso Giorgio Gaber è stato un grande
autore teatrale poeta e tra le sue
canzoni ce n'è una che è intitolata
proprio la leggerezza
Se voi mi accompagnasti in un piccolo
coro io ve la accennerei
e facilissimo Basta che facciate o o o o
al mio segno
e io ci canto su
proviamo
Grazie
[Applauso]
come misteriosa la leggerezza
è una strana cosa è una carezza che non
sai
Butta via il dolore la pesantezza
[Musica]
cerca di inventare la tua leggerezza e
volere
[Musica]
[Applauso]